[Musik]
hi Leute und willkommen zum neuen tollen
Video heute habe ich meinen Bruder
Vincent dabei und wir machen eine
Episode laufen und saufen zusammen hier
auf dem KDK
ja heute nicht so ganz heute werden
ohne das Saufen aber wir sind auf jeden
Fall
auf dem komplett voll mit Leuten die
tanzen und essen und saufen ja aber wir
wollen heute dann einfach mal das Essen
testen und futtern uns durch
Indien in London gezeigt gottlos
leckere Schale mit einer Soße
ja und ich war schon einmal kurz
ein bisschen mehr gefüllt sind ne
frisch
essen konnte
nur abgekürzt gesagt ja Karneval der
Kultur
das ist das KaDeWe KDK ist ein Fest in
Berlin wo wir die verschiedenen Kulturen
feiern und zelebrieren und es ist
eigentlich ein großer Jahrmarkt mit viel
guten Essen wir beginnen unsere
kulinarische Reise mit einer Kokosnuss
beide noch nicht probiert und
anscheinend gibt
wow probieren
auf jeden Fall besser gekauft
Bewertung
fair aber auch nur weil es jetzt nicht
so arschkalt ist weißt du wenn es
richtig erfrischend ist am Besten sein
aber vielleicht auf welchen Kater habe
und einfach Durst habe ist das so geil
an wie so das erfrischendste was es
überhaupt gibt aber stell dir das mal
noch in so kälter vorweisen ja ja so
jetzt haben wir getrunken jetzt geht's
weiter wir werden uns etwas reinladen
die rouanische Spezialitäten sind wir
hier ich glaube das sind diese Bälle da
unten
ist
ganz klar
oh es riecht sehr interessant Kaugummi
so ein bisschen ja es hat ein bisschen
was kaugummiartiges
10 von 10 du sind direkt ich muss es
erstmal irgendwie verstehen
auseinandernehmen
wir gleich weiter mit der ersten
Empanada meines Lebens ich weiß ja
oh mein Gott
Zeit so eine richtige ne also ich glaube
es gibt schon verschiedene
also ich bin kein Empanada Spezialist
aber ich glaube wir werden sie sehr gut
ganz wichtig polnische Küche gibt es
immer nur Fleischwurst Wurst Fleisch
Fleisch
aber wir haben es gesehen
Samstag hatte sie eine Möglichkeit der
Regenbogenflagge und hat im Garten
Alkohol ausgeschenkt
für eine halbe Stunde im in der Kirche
und haben gesagt
katholische Kirche
aus Afrika Küche äh was haben wir mit
Erdnuss Soße und Hähnchen ja jetzt
gibt's Fufu ist lecker
[Musik]
Kartoffel als eine Banane
nein du musst deine Kartoffeln lernen
nein
[Musik]
sehr sehr lecker also noch leckerer als
ich mir vorgestellt habe
einfach alle gut drauf sind
in Berlin gutes aus Finnland
kartoffelspirin
wow
also ich glaube die japanische Kultur
würde sich jetzt im Grabe umdrehen und
das ist doch gut oder
kannst du dein Knoblauch so ganz auf
dieser Struktur schreibst du dein
Knoblauch und dann hast du ganz fein
gemahlen oh
was man dann so auf Mangos so geil
von dir okay dann probieren wir das mal
aus mit champign Soße
ist das Gewürz und James hat so eine
Soße die auch sehr ähnlich schmeckt okay
mit Früchten
ich hätte okay
[Musik]
einfach
kommt darauf überhaupt nicht klar
als nächstes gibt es und die Schlange
ist sehr lang ich weiß nicht warum alle
möchten das Essen
ich habe gerade so ein bisschen schon
von diesem Kraut probiert das ist sehr
sehr strange
sind oktopusbällchen und ja die werden
dann dieser Pfanne drin gemacht sie
sehen wecken hier ein bisschen weich und
eigentlich sind so Oktopus Flocken drauf
bonitos locken heißen die glaube ich
hier haben sie was Zwiebeln drauf
gemacht deswegen weiß ich nicht die
authentisch das ist
oder schlecht gut
anbraten
aber ich habe gedacht bei der Schlange
auf jeden Fall in London
Blut besser okay Leute ich hoffe euch
hat das Video gefallen wir lassen uns
das jetzt ein bisschen gut gehen hier
und Essen mal alles auf und wir sehen
uns dann beim nächsten Mal wieder
tschüss